today I just had the time so I decided
I'm going to read some of my hate
comments just pearly things I don't know
her real name it's one of the worst pick
me pick me's I have ever seen all the
videos on her channel are bashing women
and glorifying pikmedom I am gonna go
out on a limb and say that she's ugly
her character is ugly and is trying
really hard to stay relevant by making
videos that only resonate with red
pilled men honestly a pathetic move from
a woman to throw other women under the
bus I know men I have four brothers I
have five brothers thank you I need a
big clown emoji that one that one is
only 25 and is already in veteran pick
me there is no chance for her